sage femme maman et consultante en
parentalité je suis chercheur
ma curiosité comme des mac avec des
élans des noces de repos enfin je moi et
mixant la minute et nouvelles parfois
vous devez vous le disait sur de devant
ne dirais pas qui était d'éviter ce
mardi à l'adolescence j'ai débattu en
jeu de rôle et icade société cité jeunes
adultes
j'ai bougé explorer dans ses voyages et
mais aussi la vie la mort et la maladie
avec mes études de sage femme j'ai
rencontré des personnes précieuse tout
axé ma curiosité
un jour une vieille histoire m'a dit
isabelle quand tu perds ça moins d eau
tu la première personne a rencontré à
toucher ce bébé comme une terre vierge
waouh ce jour là j'ai vraiment senti le
précieux le sacré de la vie et les
humains puis j'ai exploré mon la
généalogie et même ressenti puis les
arbres l'agriculture biologique et
l'écologie qui fait du lien entre
l'écologie sur terre et écologie de soi
la naissance de mes enfants elle m'a
bouleversé j'ai des noms des d'un
revendeur de tendresse d'amour mais
aussi de surprises et de questions je me
suis senti parfois démunis en détresse
incompétente à répondre aux pleurs ou
aux colères de mes enfants
alors j'ai lu j'ai cherché j'ai exploré
j'ai voulu les comprendre je crois que
devenir maman ça m'a vraiment mis en
vaut deux chercheurs définitivement si
je regarde en arrière
ma curiosité elle est comme des vagues
parfois avec des grands élans et
beaucoup d'enthousiasmé qui dépose mais
aussi parfois les repos ou commercy et
la visiter
en suspens même parfois j'ai
l'impression de l'avoir perdu
alors j'ai lu j'ai cherché j'ai exploré
et j'ai observé maison quand on voit les
apprentissages naturel les enfants qu'on
voit avec quelle ténacité qu'elle
persévérance les enfants rampe se
retourne essaye de marché pour découvrir
leur manque le monde
à aucun moment on ne peut douter de leur
curiosité elle est interne immense et
sans limite alors assurément je crois
que nous sommes tous vous et de
curiosité mais parfois c'est comme si on
avait perdu le stress un blog le penser
il apprendrait le réfléchir le besoin
d'explorer mais aussi la curiosité alors
par tous un petit peu à la recherche de
ces pauses séropos césar et qu'est ce
qui se passe pour nous
or la curiosité d'explorer le monde on
avait 16 ans et qui à un moment là les
classes de repos c'est pas de bron elles
sont nécessaires vous permettre parfois
d'intégrer ou parfois on va faire des
régressions pour explorer des
régressions certaines explorations pour
explorer d'autres explorations
parfois on va même reculer pour prendre
notre élan aura aussi se poser remplir
votre réservoir sexy passer du temps de
qualité avec nos parents ou avec les
gens qu'on aime bien des jeux des câlins
la jeune favorise la sécrétion d'un
arrêt du cerveau supérieur et donc
s'étendre bouées sont vraiment essentiel
parfois on va aussi avoir besoin
d'intégrer dans les temps les
apprentissages ya trois façons les
apprentissages hier innovation
intégration affinage immersion et
affinage on a besoin de beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé pour pouvoir explorer la
phase d'intégration c'est plutôt elle
son père quand on ne fait rien corey
vascons bull vous pouvez tout autre
chose que ce qu'on vient d'apprendre et
toutes ces phases là elles sont est
vraiment essentiel en fait pour garder
nos élan de curiosité
novak et plonger pleinement dans
formation et puis parfois on a
l'impression d'être une curiosité elle
est plutôt à l'arrêt en suspens on
n'arrive plus à explorer le monde
en fait on est bloqué quand nos besoins
sont comblés nos émotions sont
déchargées nous les humains fonctionne
bien mais parfois quand des besoins ne
sont pas à combler vos émotions sont pas
des charges et savent l'homme mais
pensez à prendre elle réfléchir par lui
nos besoins les plus importants chez
nous les humains il ya le la sécurité la
sécurité à 7,6 le respect l'amour le
besoin de reconnaissance le sentiment
d'appartenance mais aussi à lors du
contrôle sur sa vie le contact physique
affectueux et dans les besoins
physiologiques des besoins a donc dormi
et mangé éliminé rouge et explorer
jouets sont des besoins importants
si je me suis je vois pas je meurs si je
n'y vais pas je veux ça faisait tous
peut-être déjà arrivé gagnon dans la
voiture vous êtes sur l'autoroute
et puis elle va bientôt pour vous avez
envie d'aller aux toilettes au début ça
va et que finalement on est comme ça on
pense plus qu'à ça on a du mal à se
concentrer sur la conduit on n'a plus
aucune patience avec nos enfants
et puis alors le paysage on le regarde
pas c'est sur notre cerveau archaïque
il est programmé pour pouvoir nous
donner la formation pour nos besoins
doivent être comblées et donc ça va
mettre notre cerveau sous stress
généralement c'est la fac
l'agressivité dont quand nos enfants des
comportements qui sont mal supporté par
nous ont déjà vu qui ont des
comportements qui sont mal supporté
aussi la première chose à faire c'est
vérifié s'il aurait pas avoir un besoin
un congrès et de combler ça va nous
aider à bien fonctionner merci les
émotions les émotions c'était c'est un
moment qui vient de l'intérieur qui va
vers l'extérieur ici au monde qui je
suis et qu'est ce qui se passe pour moi
hormis les émotions il ya la colère la
tristesse la peur mais aussi la joie si
dans ma vie à du stress est un stress je
vais alors une émotion
en fait elle me charge une tension et
une décharge émotionnelle l'avait chargé
elle sait les pleurs les colères les rhc
ce qui n'était pas ce qui était interdit
vous dévalorisez quand on était enfants
mais maintenant c'est grâce aux
neurosciences que cette décharge
émotionnelle elle est essentielle pour
bien fonctionner à nous permet de guérir
de grandir de nous libérer des
événements déclencheurs elle pas facile
la compagnie puisque comme elle n'a pas
été autorisée quand on était enfant elle
pas facile à accompagner pour nous mêmes
cette décharge émotionnelle va nous
permettre de bien fonctionner et d'aller
beaucoup mieux après pourpoint se
retrouver notre point d'équilibré nous
sommes naturellement coopératif aimant
et joyeux nous les humains je me suis vu
aussi coupé les landes les enfants elle
un jour l'allemand dans la voiture et
c'est fait elle part explorer la voiture
et moi je m'agace je m'énerve parce
qu'elle vient pas souvent immédiatement
sur le sujet et pourtant je suis pas
familier
alors du coup j'ai lu j'ai cherché à
explorer la mémoire traumatique nos
blessures n'en faut quand on fait des
commentaires négatifs sur les enfants
quand on pose des étiquettes dit elle
est dévalorisant quand on leur balance
nos peurs
quand on sature leur mémoire de travail
contre eux car leur enthousiasme ou
leurs trajets d'apprentissage la
curiosité
elle va s'affaiblir et puis se dessécher
et se ratatiner alors pourquoi ces
salles mais les adultes parce que c'est
notre mémoire matic quand on s'est senti
blessé quand on était enfant dans les
mêmes circonstances
le souvenir est allée se loger dans une
petite partie de notre cerveau
émotionnel l'amygdale et pièces et elle
est restée là comme ça à l'intérieur et
quand adultes danse on retrouve dans une
dans une situation similaire
l'amygdale elle va se réactiver comme
une autoroute et consorts c'est comme si
on sortait de nous comme si on était
contrôlée par nos émotions
et comme si on était coupé 2 2 de
l'amour pour nos enfants
alors bien évidemment peut faire lui il
ya une autre histoire
et puis travailler dessus pour l'apaiser
et petit à petit ça marche je me suis
retrouvé donc à venir la ceinture de
sécurité 60 ans
elle vient asseoir pendant un petit
moment et puis ça s'est abaissée et j'ai
réussi à passer le cap
cette question chez moi alors qu'est ce
qui favorise la curieuse chaque pomme on
va encourager les projets chaque fois
qu'on va revaloriser les airs comme
faisant partie du chemin et qu'on va me
permettre d'en aux enfants d'être libres
d'explorer leur élan de curiosité leur
enthousiasme leurs mécanismes
d'apprentissage alors on va participer à
favoriser leur curiosité mais aussi
chaque fois qu'ils vont recevoir de
l'affection de l'attention à regard
positif inconditionnel ça va les aider à
développer les meilleurs sites de même
une grande confiance en eux et à donner
leur plein potentiel pour être hauteur
de leur vie
il ya autant de formes d'intelligence
autant de chemins de curiosité que tu
m'insultes en soutenant cela est prêt
avant cela alors avec mon métier de
sage-femme ya quelques années une
découvert la physiologie de la naissance
et l'ocytocine le site aussi de
l'hormone de l'amour et l'attachement lé
potentiel au moment de la naissance mais
aussi à tous les âges de la vie
alors que ces lentilles d'eau l'antilope
pour pouvoir mettre au monde son bébé
elle va aller chercher mon véhicule et
du coup d'adrénaline lors notre place
pavée s'embrasser et puis ocytocine
leurs moines de l'amour et l'attachement
qui va favoriser un accouchement rapide
elle va monter à l'eso mais je n'ai
jamais atteint à d'autres moments dans
la vie
mais si la rue la lionne road elle est
en danger mais je peux partir je peux me
sauver avec mon bébé dans mon ventre je
peux me soumet avec mon bébé dans mes
bras mais je ne peux pas me sauver
moment où le bébé sort donc c'est
seulement en fait oui il faut de
l'adrénaline parce que c'est un moment
qui doit être extrêmement bref parce que
la mer et dont on en extrait d'une
arabité en grande ouverture et que le
fait qu'elles peuvent à son souper à ce
moment là c'est aussi moment il ya
besoin d'adrénaline
parce que parce qu'en fait c'est le
nôtre naissance est notre plus grand
défi
notre vie c'est le moment qu'ont choisi
de quitter la sécurité du nord de la mer
pour sortir et se lancer dans la mode
lui donc c'est un grand défi de la vie
et jettent expliquerait pourquoi là bas
ils participent à nos débuts dans la vie
alors du coup j'ai lu j'ai cherché à
explorer l'ocytocine est la vraie n'est
pas si facile à l'adrénaline c'est des
hormones c'est des messagers chimiques
du corps et quand on veut bien l'écouter
notre corps en fait ils donnent tous les
messages pour bien fonctionner c'est
désolant dossiers qui sont contagieuses
savait déjà dû sentir dans une pièce en
commun on sent si l'ambiance est
chaleureuse où si l'ambiance est
électrique
l'adrénaline elle va participer à la
survie de notre espèce mais aussi tous
nos défis on l'a vu avec la naissance
tout neuf et immobilisant de travail
notre nos activités extérioriser mais
aussi l'établissement de nos limites
de l'autre côté l'ocytocine est là elle
va pas brisé c'est un départ de guérison
elle va favoriser leur peau la
récupération grandir guérilla se réparer
être en lien avec les autres trouver des
ressources aussi à la meilleure une
meilleure résistance au stress et
pourquoi aller chercher nos ressources
en interne pour traverser les
difficultés de la vie
malheureusement dans notre société
souvent c'est aussitôt signer sa tasse à
thé qu'il y ocytocine à annalynne à qui
devrait permettre de bien fonctionner et
qui pour notre bonne santé la survie de
notre espèce
elle est souvent en déséquilibre alors
j'imagine que vous voyez bien de quel
peuple et je parle de technique et je
parle nous sommes en surcharge
d'adrénaline dans nos sociétés nous
sommes dans un stress chronique
la pression sociale scolaire en terme de
réussite de performance tout va très
vite tourner une ondée images on est en
stress chronique et du coup ça va
favoriser cette surcharge de
d'adrénaline qui valent à favoriser
aussi c'est qu'on oublie on d'epargne a
dévalorisé pendant pendant longtemps ce
temps de récupération de repos de
prendre soin de soirée etc et donc du
coup le fait de ne pas prendre ce temps
favorise encore et accentue encore le
déséquilibrant
le problème c'est que les effets de ce
déséquilibre
ils sont vraiment toxique pour nous
l'excès de cortisol et d'internât line
en fait et toxiques pour notre pour nos
neurones
elle développe les apprentissages et
puis ça favorise les comportements
d'agressivité d'individualisme de
compétition on peut se sentir sans force
sans courage à social on peut s'isoler
on voit les autres comme un des dangers
oui et le monde aussi est on se coupe en
fait de soi et des autres
le problème aussi c'est que cette ce
déséquilibre les essais de ce déclic
sont aussi aggravé par le fait de nos
questions d'enfants qu'on a peur
et puis aussi par l'injonction de
perfection qu'on a reçu
cette injonction perception elle nous
porte vraiment prévu elle est vraiment
lourd dans notre société
elle nous coûte de nous et de notre rosé
de la peur de t on à peur d'essayer
alors l'ocytocine je cite aussi la halle
à ne pas permettre c'est un hectare de
guérison elle pas favoriser la
coopération l'empathie la bienveillance
là les apprentissages la jeu permet de
nous ressasser le stress suis en
déséquilibre
l'empathie la bienveillance la
créativité la curiosité les
apprentissages
elles font lire avec les autres merci
elle m'a parlé des liens avec les autres
la coopération l'altruisme allait aussi
devoir d'avoir une vision plus large de
la vie et de quoi prendre soin prendre
soin de soi des autres et de la planète
elle nous permet d'aller chercher plus
facilement nos ressources et aussi de
d'avant plaisir à être avec les autres
donc il me semble d'être pleinement
humain alors pourquoi pour moi c'est le
secret des humains c'est parce que aussi
possible c'est une hormone qui n'a pas
une place ont comme les autres les
autres quand on atteint place on arrête
dans sécréter qui en
quand on atteint un plancher en enr
secret c'est de cette hormone en fait
plus on a deux puis on sécrète puma
facilité on sait fêter plus navré cet
oral si possible puis on sécrète pur de
faciliter l arcep l'été pour l'adresse
est aussi possible et en cela je trouve
que c'est le sait qu elle se crée des
humains parce que en fait elle est à la
peine d'être dispo dispositions
individuelles gratuites alors à ce stade
j'imagine que vous vous demandez comment
floride est aussi possible voilà allez
on fabrique de l'ocytocine chaque fois
qu'on fait les choses qui nous font
plaisir dans d'autres quand on est avec
des gens qu'on aime quand on mange
quelque chose qui me fait plaisir quand
on voit un beau paysage
quand on fait une activité qui nous fait
vibrer mais aussi les câlins les
massages le contact physique et
affectueux le jeu quand on reçoit du
soutien la chaleur de l'empathie un
regard positif inconditionnels fait
fabriquer d'ocytocine et même de penser
avec vous souvenez ou à des personnes
qu'on aime nous fabriquer aussi possible
et du coup ça va nous permettre de
rééquilibrer de se retrouver dans cet
équilibre
adrénaline ocytocine où on a besoin
d'être heureuse de cette fois réparé
pour avoir faire face aux anneaux à nos
décideurs
alors si je peut synthétiser
du coup on peut regarder les besoins et
les émotions pour qu'on puisse être
connectée à notre curiosité les besoins
et les émotions
elle est de remettre les pédos à lui
qu'on doit être comblé les émotions des
charges et on peut travailler sur notre
hub de notre mémoire pharmacie pour
essayer de faire autrement changer de
regard sur les enfants et puis remet de
l'ocytocine dans nos vies des choses qui
nous font du bien
pour être dans l'équilibré il ya autant
de formes d'un région ce que tu fais un
super avec vous et si ma favorite est
grandement l'ocytocine c'est pour nous
les humains c'est de recevoir un rare
cas positifs un professionnel ça ne
donne vraiment des ailes pour être
pleinement humain il prend soin de soi
des autres et de la fête
et n'oubliez pas on a besoin par moments
d'avant des salles de repos où on va
pouvoir intégrer en fait
combien de voir combien de temps
d'explorer alors comment préserver la
curiosité des enfants
on peut les observer et chaque fois que
c'est possible
respecter leur rythme leur émotion de
leur ressenti leur besoin leur
vulnérabilité et leur immaturité et
soumettre à la hauteur de leurs
sentiments accueillir leurs êtres
vivants et enthousiaste dire oui à la
vie
il ya plein pour d'entrée pour changer
le monde mais celle que j'ai choisie et
qui je pense sera très efficace à long
terme c'est le poêle à bois du soutien à
la parentalité pour changer de regard
sur les enfants j'accompagne les parents
les professionnels pour se reconnecter
au point la vie et de la relation pour
retrouver leur siège pour recouvrer
leurs chercheurs leur curiosité pour se
comprendre même et comprendre alors pour
leurs enfants pour qu'ils puissent
garder intacte la figure des idées des
enfants demain être gourde chercheurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]